what would you say is a secret then to
remaining positive in a town where some
people do want to see succeed and others
for maybe their own insecurities or
whatever it is that's going on with them
don't how do you remain maybe me is it
just an even keel is it trying to remain
at a high level in your mind in terms of
being happy being upbeat what do you
think is the key you live your life
between the jobs and the auditions
that's what everyone forgets is that you
know it's easy to be happy and up and
positive when you're working if that's
easy but what we forget is that our
lives happen between those jobs you know
and I remember when I first got here the
incessant sunshine was tyrannical you
know it was like it's because I came
from the East Coast originally in every
place I lived elsewhere had weather you
know even Northern California had
weather and Southern California is sunny
every day you know it's you don't really
have reference points about remember
what was snowing that day when we went
out or you are running a train park oh I
love that yes that's when we did that
thing no it's sunny and you know 70 all
the time so so when I first got here the
tyranny of the sunshine made me think oh
it's a perfect day I should be out and
doing something I should be
accomplishing something I should be
trying to get a job or need a better
agent or or you know something I should
be doing something and then I finally
dawned on me that oh no it's a beautiful
day and I don't really have an
appointment go to the beach I'm gonna go
to the beach I'm gonna take a picnic I'm
gonna go or I'm going to go for a hike
or I'm going to go for a drive or I'm
going to live my life people just
suspend their existence so often between
their shots you know and so to live your
life and to give yourself credit for the
things that you have accomplished and
the things that you're trying for and to
realize that you are so much luckier
than you realize
I mean we go right because we're because
we're
with a big brass ring we passed by the
shiny penny on the street which is an
indication that hey there's a shiny
penny that's for me that's luck look at
that and say oh that's a little sign
that money's come in my way or you're
running a little bit late and a parking
space opens up where it is you're going
that's a little miracle thank you
whoever yeah it is in a way but those
are we have to acknowledge that all the
good things all the tiny little miracles
that happen every day acknowledge them
and if you acknowledge them you'd be
amazed at how many more start coming
your way and here's something that I
learned I'd never heard this before but
many years ago someone said to me you
know about the shiny penny thing and I
would always pick up a penny and they
said you know what I heard was it's best
if you pick it when it's heads up if it
scales up don't pick it up but what you
do is you find a penny when it scales up
you turn it over so it's heads up for
the next person so you're sharing the
concept that good things happen and that
luck is out there and you know if you
get in line and it moves quickly if you
are at the bank and and the teller is
nice to you if you're out with your
friends the bartender buys you around
these are all indications that things
are going well in your life well you
know when I came here Facebook didn't
exist on the generation Xer so photo
media wasn't around the internet wasn't
only only some you know obscure a
computer engineer knew about it but now
everybody who comes here is on their
phone and they see other people having
great things happen to them but I think
that and I've especially seen this in
Millennials there's like this social
media envy or there's all this stuff is
happening for other people because we're
comparing all this great stuff that
they're putting out right compared to
our own life what's your advice for
people that yeah they want to say hey
congratulations on LinkedIn someone so
just got this that's great but then they
feel what when is it my turn right well
my advice would be look up
don't be here all the time you know I
swear that subsequent generations are
going to have little needle thumbs there
everything is going to be adapted you
know to just poking little dots you know
little letters do the thing look up get
your head out of your technological ass
let's stop here I like it and and and
look at the people around you and it
really interact with the living beings
or in front of you right now I know
you've seen this too but you know you go
out you see people at a table together
and they're texting each other or other
people and you're right about the about
suit I remember I said earlier to stop
comparing ourselves to other people
because you have no idea what their
journey is or what is what they're
saying is even true Facebook and and and
and texting and all of these other
things give you the impression that
everybody else is having all the fun
doing all the traveling having all the
sex meeting all the great stars you know
and just realize you just cut that in
half by 50% and that may be closer to
the truth about what they're really
doing in their lives but look up don't
be here this is not what we're about you
know we're about our brothers and
sisters in the world all over the world
and to be and think you don't be in the
if you're at the market and you see
somebody whose hair is beautiful tell
them that that's pretty tell them you
love that jacket tell them you love that
outfit which I do by the way
oh say nice things to other people stop
making it all about you because when
it's all about you no matter how
successful you are it can be pretty
freaking bleak because you're not
relating to the rest of the world
there's so much around us that is
interesting and fun and and diverting
you know and and we just can't locked
into this and it's it's such a it's it's
actually toxic for you because you know
as I think you refer to the Millennials
and the college students there have been
psychological studies about the mass
increase in depressed college students
who spend so much time on Facebook and
comparing themselves to everybody else
it is a psychological toxin and the way
to get rid of toxins is to cleanse your
body with with you know getting outside
of yourself and and reaching out to
other people stop thinking about you all
the time
right and no one post pictures of
themselves going through a depression on
Facebook they don't post pictures of
themselves not being able to get out of
bed they play I'm here with so-and-so
look who I met at this screening all
right which is great but I think then we
have a false idea of how well other
people's lives are compared to our own
and that causes just yeah a lot of
insecurities a lot of insecurities in
this town see time insecurity it does
yeah and I think as a younger person
they don't realize that at first well
you know and I think that's important
for for people to be aware of yes they
can find their own things a hobby
whatever right that they can focus on
that's not about looks it's not about
status right yeah and and being nice to
other people taking a minute to say a
kind word it takes nothing from you and
what you get back is I mean I actually
drive down the street sometimes there is
an older band standing on the corner
waiting for a bus and I rolled look
acting like you roll down the window
anymore I roll down my window huh and I
said that's a fabulous jacket and he
looked up and he smiled and and you have
no idea what the kind thing you just did
or said right what that person is going
through you may have just lifted them
sure in a moment of despair and you also
get a charge oh my god forgiving someone
yeah it becomes a little bit addictive
yes nice feeling yeah cuz you see maybe
he did look down or whatever he was just
and then you write changed his face
right
you